yeah you can't talk about much uh racial  jokes that's hard to pull off let's try  one  um  white privilege you hear about that a  lot now white privilege but i thought it  was all about diversity so shouldn't we  talk about everybody's privileges why  are we just limiting it to whitey let's  spread the love let's make every group  feel good everybody's got something tall  people privileged see the concert  jews no hell  pretty good pretty good women ladies  night that's cool black people i can't  wear a purple suit  looks like fun  everybody's got a perk indian people  even if you're undateable your parents  will arrange something  let's spread the love